or the Commission had proposed forty
thousand refugees to be relocated from
Italy in Greece which is a well a small
number and that's what we say in the
report know very clearly that this is an
initial number that whenever they're all
like when the Commission comes up with a
permanent relocation scheme which would
happen in the end of the year then the
number needs to be much more substantial
40,000 can only be the start in Greece
has a particular problem because and
they now have overtaken Italy as in the
number of arrivals they have very poor
facilities especially on the islands or
no facilities because it the numbers
have really gone up and clearly a grace
has very big economic problems so they
have already been food shortages for
Refugees and I really think that the
European needs to be doing more about
this I think it's really great pity that
member states couldn't agree to a
binding mechanism but then they promised
that they will take on more forty
thousand refugees and still they haven't
provided enough numbers to adapt to
those 40,000 so I think if that does not
happen until Monday it will really be a
blow into the face of European Union
Solidarity